hi my name is chris dodd's well and I
was just wondering what your opinions on
string theory are and what do you think
it's provable or not hi Chris you're
asking about string theory well I'm not
the right person to ask that's not my
subject I actually like to measure
things instead of making theories about
them but I can tell you why string
theory was invented if you try to
calculate the energy of a particle that
has a just a point in space and you
calculate the few the energy in the
electric field around an electron the
answer that you get is infinity this is
not the right answer so if you could
imagine that instead of being a point
the particle is actually spread out into
a string or a surface or other ways you
can avoid this infinity problem and then
it becomes a much more interesting
calculation and this has worked out
pretty well mathematically so we're
beginning to be able to do that but
unfortunately there is very little way
that we can tell the difference between
string theory predictions and other
theory predictions they've all been
adjusted to match the reality that we've
already observed so so far a string
theory has not made predictions that
haven't already been tested that means
it's not possible to demonstrate that
it's a better theory than others but
maybe that time will come
perhaps a string theory will predict
something that will be seen that the
Large Hadron Collider that no other
theory has predicted in that case then
we would say it was a great success